i wish there was a way to
uh because everything you just said now
it makes a lot of sense doesn't it
i'm being indoctrinated on air no i
think there's just uh jessica
was just a fun random guy who just
wanted to make home movies the
presidents
um well you think i'm just some random
guy i'm just
trying to sell myself as somebody who's
friendly with the american audience i
believe you are
backed by people that want people to be
more comfortable with robot dogs
i believe that i believe you're pushed
to be the happy face of ai
which is why you should hit this part
no editing joe rogan's rule no editing
this is live
no i mean i wish there was a way to for
some of the conspiracy theories to prove
that that's not the case
like what the the cia is there is some
possibility in my mind
that institutions like the cia and
different kind of
organizations are driven less by
organized malevolence and more by just
incompetence just bureaucracy being
incompetent i think that argument gets
less and less persuasive when you look
at all the things they've been able to
do right
now it's it's very certain just you said
that
there's a bunch of them that have done
because there's some conspiracy theories
that are dramatic and true
the question is i wish there was a way
to prove
that some of them are not and it's very
difficult because
so much has shrouded mystery like one
you know one of the things i'm bothered
by is when people accuse other like
athletes of using steroids for example
right and it's just yes a lot of people
use steroids but it sucks the
that people just don't believe you like
uh there's some incredible athletes that
look shredded that look
just incredible performers and everybody
uh just says that they're on steroids
they kind of assume yeah
i mean and that and people accuse me all
the time of being on
performance-enhancing drugs and steroids
and it is
hard but what i remind them is it's what
my my my my my appearance as a result of
dedication
uh but hard work diet exercise
are you on keto uh i'm on i'm on key
i'm doing a version of your keto right
yeah so i'm doing a version of keto
right now with bread
and it's do you see what i mean your
carb up sort of
you know with sugar called keto blood
sugar and it's a very it's a good diet
for i grew up in the 90s when nobody
ever lost weight sadly because
every diet was like you can eat what you
want just be accountable
no one even knew what that man so it
would be like my mother being like if
you have chocolate chip pancakes have a
glass of water
yeah just take a walk around the block
yeah you can go to mcdonald's three
times a day
just walk around the block that's what
my parents used to say like my mother be
like just
walk around the block you're fine um
gonna have a cigarette walk 20 steps
walk 20 steps back
it's exercise so um no i
there's too many conspiracies out there
a lot of them are true a lot of them are
bitter angry people trying to justify
their own
uh impotence not being able to do
anything in life and they're like the
people that have done something in life
they're all nefarious it's all that the
card just act against me that's 100 true
100 it attracts usually people
that have not figured out a way to
succeed and
or haven't succeeded on the level that
they want to
but that also being true there are there
is a fair amount of [ __ ]
going on and provable and you know
we just have to i think separate uh
separate know that these things are
often inflated or not true but know that
sometimes they are true
otherwise it wouldn't exist if there was
no if there was nothing to jfk
there was nothing to 9 11 if there was
if people felt like they were being
dealt with honestly
this wouldn't exist i mean this exists
because there are
real questions that people have that
don't get answered for whatever reason
and then the vacuum of the refusal to
answer those questions that that
information vacuum
is filled with people like alex jones
who are curious and sometimes they're
right and sometimes they're
horribly wrong and sometimes they're all
over the place
a good story tells and people love
stories and yeah when there's an
absence of actual alex is a uniquely
american
person like very interesting i don't
know how many countries like how many
people make a living as a conspiracy
theorist a good living in other
countries right it's very rare right
i mean it's very interesting and he
became like i know people that knew him
when he was a kid because i go to austin
and perform a lot
and you know he was a guy that would
take a bull horn and yell at cops
because he thought dewey checkpoints
were unconstitutional that's what he was
doing in college
and he just went through he was hated by
the right he was hated by the bush
people he was hated by the
and he went from being this this this
guy that was considered like
a a leftist even like even though he's
never left this
he was considered this like enemy of
mainstream conservatism like he was not
and that he considered a guy that wasn't
a patriot wasn't this wasn't that
and he just wow like he whines and
whines and ends up
just being this confidant of a
republican president a very divisive
republican president
and he becomes this populist and
everything like that it's really wild to
watch that but
i mean i do think he should retire
eventually just so we could get
you know some i don't know it seems like
a it's a lot to keep doing well i hope
this world
allows for alex jones to continue having
a voice
because just like you said he's uh
i use the word fun but really he he
shakes up the norms of our discourse
i do too i do think we need to put more
value i think entertainment
you know we need we do need to say that
like there are people that should be
allowed to have a voice for
entertainment purposes
right and that's par and that's part of
what donald trump now that he's not the
president
come on let the guy let him talk
you